greetings from podcast Ville the church
or what's happened now is brought to you
by stamps.com listen how busy are you
gonna be this holiday season with
errands and this and this and that
especially at the post office that's why
you gotta use temps calm it saves you so
much time during this hectic holiday
season stamps out calm brings all the
services of the US Post Office right to
your desktop by and print official US
postage for any letter any package any
class mail using your own computer and
printer than the mail carrier picks it
up no trips to the post office acquired
it couldn't be easier what I'm gonna do
is this how you stamps out calm my wife
uses it to send our t-shirts or mugs
it is a tremendous service and right now
you can enjoy the stamps calm service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps calm right now
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in Joey Jo eey
that stamps calm and - Joey listen
you're not gonna be sorry whether your
business is small or large stamps calm
is the way to go the church what's
happen now is also brought to you by on
it listen on it's doing some great
[ __ ] things over there I mean I live
and die with them damn babe with us
since the beginning and you guys know I
used all their products from the [ __ ]
kettle bells to the shrimp exports with
shrimp Tek immune it's Christmas time
they just had a sale and they keep the
sale keeps going on if I was you guys
I'm gonna start the year off with a bang
go to Anna comrade now I'm pressing
Church start off with the Alpha brand if
you don't like the Alpha brand it's 100
percent money-back guarantee and they
don't want the product back who does
that who want was less time you bought
weed you didn't like it you brought it
nut never gonna calm right now I'm press
in church bad and get 10% off and it
gets delivered right the house alright
it's Monday December 3rd let's get this
party started
kick this [ __ ] melee happy Monday the
you [ __ ] what's happening Rikki
Rockett in the house what's in the house
so good to see you man it to see
whoa you had me on her because you're
spectacular because you're spectacular
you know what it's nice because I had to
go see the ex-wife before I came over
here go drop some stuff off to the kids
and it made me think about something I
remember that when I was seeing her when
we were together
somebody stole my credit card right but
I never bothered to report it because
the guy that stole what was spending
less than her stress you can use that
that's for you
now the ex-wife how's your relationship
it's fine yeah yeah yeah we're civil
that's the most important [ __ ] thing
you know the ex-wife Walker be [ __ ] huh
well we've been through that too you
know so now you're civil
yeah yeah yeah for the sake of the kids
man you know they say stay together for
the kids no go apart and learn to work
together apart that's the best for the
kids and when you can't get along we did
everything we could and it just wouldn't
work when people stay together for the
kids the kids see it absolutely I never
see what yeah they do
they don't the kids feel it and you're
doing the kids at this justice anyway
yeah yeah you know divorce is a [ __ ]
mother [ __ ] I was a little guy this
weekend like that divorce after 37 years
like 37 years how old's a guy let's say
he's 60
you know what are you gonna do what do
you do like I would that would be as
honest as I am with you guys it would be
my biggest fear losing my wife because I
would be completely lost
well I mean like George Bush he was lost
when Barbara died lost why he died I
mean I entrusted in my it was old too
don't get me wrong but I mean you know
it might be after my mom went my dad was
a year behind her yeah my wife is my
like I don't know anything I don't know
anything about the house the mortgage
the friends
a cop ain't that funny how they wind up
right right I'll show she's an
accountant by trade she's an accountant
this is what she does
oh man you know did you have a prenup oh
I couldn't have a pretty how can you
have a prenup with somebody who saw you
grow from nothing I couldn't have a
prenup well yeah that's different I
would not eat my ex-wife came into it I
was already poison had already done
right we you know we were you know I
mean we're all our pivotal records had
already been recorded by the time we got
involved I'm talking you move out here
from Pennsylvania moving with a girl
sleeps in the car with you for a week
until you find an apartment right
doesn't give you signal
yeah you get an apartment whether you
have your ups and downs awesome you join
a band you get a what are you gonna do
dumper the commoner you're gonna have on
you I did know the Karma that's gonna be
on you is there'd be the stench of ten
dead [ __ ] monkeys yeah so you don't
want that stench on you so somebody help
in there with you but here's another
side of that calling that when I got
married I got married because she stuck
it out with me in prison yeah yeah the
first wife the first wife when I came
out I felt obliged even though we were
having ups and downs I felt like she
stuck it out with me and of marrying it
and it backfired yeah so there's two
sides to every calling yes yeah but you
know my girl went through you know all
the cancer stuff with me but it it
wasn't like I don't feel obliged I mean
of course I do to some degree but that's
not why I'm with her I feel like she
showed me the side of her that I was
looking for in somebody there was other
candidates you know any man but somebody
that will you know really stand by you I
mean come on man that's gold you know
any man I mean it's just you Kayla I'll
never forget that her and I had been
dating about two or three years but at
that time they were I don't know if it
was a na they did a series
of stories about different actors and
comics and they did a story about
Kennison Oh
welcome to they go that he dated a girl
in the beginning and dumped him and she
knew he was just using her you know
right I'll never forget that my wife at
the time after like two or three years
looked at Michigan's I hope you've you
you'll never do anything like that you
know yeah you ever happened did you know
Kennison know it yeah I did and I did
she she hung out with him a lot a lot
right ccz of them was I about it they
were that was and so therefore I saw him
a lot you know in a man personally I
think CC is Whittier and funnier than
Sam Kinison you have no I thought there
was a time when I first moved here where
I'd CCC and he'd honestly make me laugh
there's people who make you laugh with
with their wit but there's people at
their body language cracks me the [ __ ]
up and CC is one of those guys II see
the guitar player from poison okay
gotcha yeah that's really weird he's
from Brooklyn yeah so he's got that
natural character you know who else is
like that Ace Frehley yeah yes
Ace Frehley I think in the early
interviews I can't control myself some
nights I go into a kiss hall and I get
it you know early ones when gene would
be furious and Ace Frehley would be high
as [ __ ] cracking Josh remember one song
some interview he was doing he was
talking laughing about something where
they said you know what else are we
gonna do be plumbers yeah it's about a
jean-jacques wall serious you know he's
Holland yeah but the last couple
interviews I see them with nemesis he
got clean and sober he's not that funny
no oh so he's more yes which I love ace
no disrespect to him I just think ever
since he got sober like he's just a
little bit more tighter down his
interviews all right now they don't
sorry like a kicked on the kiss reunion
or not reunion but they supposedly it's
gonna be the last tour
talking about right it's gotta be with
ace and Peter don't you think I don't
think Peter Oh Melissa that is causing
that tour isn't it that tour could be
they could I would look at that stone
stickers for 800 right
I think this kissing on me tour could be
1200 ticket and then you get away with
it but they gotta have ace and they
gotta have the other guy but then
something else happened that destroyed
the tour it's done yes you're [ __ ]
crazy
because last Monday on what's-his-name
show they had a hole they busted out
Paul Stanley his voice is gone is it
he's gonna do this to a lip-syncing
serious the people that are in the know
like in music oh yeah Paul Stanley got
that operation and instead of recovering
properly not even part of the KISS Army
no this is what I learned just listen to
that guy on Mondays what's his name
I don't know huh the guy I'm serious
like Jim Florentines buddy they did they
have a metal show together okay you know
Michael trunk Eddie trunk Oh Eddie try
to show I love I get in the car just
listen to [ __ ] Eddie ya know Eddie's
to [ __ ] so last Monday busted out I
caught the tail end I had the baby yeah
I had to take it a Muay Thai you know
the first ten minutes of Muay Thai could
sit outside my wife's wither but I have
to go watch the class so I just heard
the thing that they're doing the tour
but they they talk to people because
they thought not bro they've been
taunting people they did the kids cruise
and they had [ __ ] gene ace come on
and do two songs you know these kids
people are serious poison people a
serious Led Zeppelin people are serious
well you know you remember as a child
growing up in Pennsylvania yeah and I've
always used this argument because
America forgets this argument there was
a time before 1979 that no matter what
[ __ ] album you like there was always
one [ __ ] in the circle that said it
doesn't matter if the let it skin it's
good but they're not better than the
Beatles wait till the Beatles get back
together do you remember that
John Lennon got shot there was always
one [ __ ] nerd in the room that didn't
like whatever there was always like that
you know the hallway so is you know one
day so yeah you you with six sixteen
year olds of the room and you listen to
the new poison out and four of us and
one guy is always the well you know the
bass sounds off there's always that one
there's always that one then there's
always that one jerk-off at the end that
goes which is good but it doesn't matter
wait till the Beatles get back together
there was always that woman ass up I
couldn't I was so happy that they John
Lennon got shot because all those people
[ __ ] having a [ __ ] cousin I was
happy and sad at the same time because
now I could win an argument okay I can
finally win a [ __ ] hour [ __ ] you with
the Beatles it's over but it was weird I
can just I don't even know how we got
the topic take it seriously with their
band man they take it very seriously you
know these people listen man man you're
a fan of whoever you pay whatever you
see the prices will be talking about
yeah there's no money in music no so
there's no money in music sales so that
money has to come from somewhere right
right a lot of stuff is live stuff and
like I said like devil City Angels my
side band we're negotiating with a label
in Australia they want to do a single at
a time that's how they want to do they
want it they don't care about a full
record all once like where you go lock
up for two three months make a record
and then and then release it and then
keep releasing single they want to do a
one song at a time and it makes sense
it's like back to the 50s you know any
man because that's how people consume it
now one thing at a time quick you know
it's not necessarily a bad thing I mean
I just think you have to look at it at
the industry a little differently people
were just like oh my god they're just so
doomsday about the music industry now
what up and you know a lot of things
happen a lot of things change and a lot
of people [ __ ] about the internet it's
the [ __ ] Internet
you know it's a lot of things happen
I mean cultural shifts and all sorts of
stuff you know rock and roll wasn't as
dangerous as it used to be it's just not
and I think that hurt rock and roll and
rock and roll were albums wrap were
albums that was the last thing to go it
was always the CDs you know and I mean
the seed the albums and then of course
his CDs and the CDs were the last things
to go in the last places that it went
were the people who were buying rap
albums you know rock went and then were
Appling but dangerous no more we were
raised on them you'd give me seven
dollars for a novel concept like I was
just thinking about this guy I don't
know how much music I write what I don't
know how many millions of dollars I've
spent on albums they got lost I read
bought them just a collection the vinyl
I gave away the vinyl collection I gave
away in 84 broke my heart like it was
one of those things where you had to
turn you back and I don't I get my car
with tear roll I got a I got a story and
I don't even want to tell you because it
would just implicate somebody so bad but
somebody put my records out in the
[ __ ] ring okay I'm talking alleged
suppling to all kinds of [ __ ] the who
Tommy all kinds of [ __ ] gone [ __ ] gone
my collection from I'm not gonna say who
it is what do you like it that situation
yeah especially if you have that type of
collection
I can't even verbalize the things I've
thought of you know I could get me
arrested
I can't imagine people just go to jail
what not Tchibo what's the name villain
sunset the music place gazebo Amina
amoeba yeah you got on me but drop
$20,000 I was great music collection
yeah that's one thing yeah that's one
thing which I refused to do I like no
I'm still into the I feel bad that I
gave away my albums in 84 I had no
choice I gave to somebody who was a
metalhead chick who still has them who I
trust there the whole thing
but now that I love these [ __ ] outs
yeah I know I'm what I love I love going
over to this place over here on in
Burbank and I go in there and I walk
around for an hour like a [ __ ] my
psychiatry albums are bitching you don't
know I'm there were firms right that
that's all they did was come up with
album concepts and photography and
graphics and stuff and now that's a
digital form and those companies are
gone and people have moved on but I mean
I mean people would just be like when
they're I mean how many kids did you
know in school right that the thing they
wanted to do was grow up and be an
artist for an album cover I want to do
album covers I'm gonna do art for album
covers I mean it literally begged people
to create another art form you know the
square that would open up you know any
man and and we don't have that anymore I
mean yeah sure there's a few but it's
not like a lot
no I always say that they took away that
whole listen I grew up on Saturday
mornings watching cartoons so how then
we tell the American kids you watch
cartoons
once you outgrew that it got to the
point where you want on your whatever
your main street was in your hometown
where they had the sporting goods and
they had the comic book store and they
had the music store you know all in
different parts man you and your buddies
would walk for miles without complaining
in the wintertime humidity
you know fleas the whole [ __ ] thing
it didn't matter where today you
wouldn't do that glad you know that
feeling had gone to the record store and
like you'll never get something I'm
gonna get sabotage you're gonna get Pink
Floyd metal and Louise didn't get
Rolling Stones made in the shade but
then we get down and when you'd find
something cooler you'd find Metallica
on whatever we changed there was
something to that no let me tell you
something it would be like I don't
remember what day of the week but I
would get my allowance for doing you
know chores and stuff like that and I'd
go right down to I think Corvettes the
basement EJ Corvettes I and
and sometimes I just look at the cover
and go through all these covers and find
like the coolest looking cover and go
I'm just gonna try this and sometimes
you [ __ ] up it would be like horrible
you'd be like ah but I discovered [ __ ]
like UFO and stuff like that just by the
cover to cover because I thought it was
so cool
I'm like it's a they've got to have a
good they have to have good music if
they put this much into the cover that's
where my head one no I had to and you
know so I try you made you try things
now it's it's a whole different way I
mean they did this social experiment
they asked all these kids you know hey
what would you rather have snapchat or
would you rather have iTunes and like 70
percent said we'd rather have snapchat I
can't even wrap my head around that can
you know you know music is like
ancillary to like a lot of kids growing
up now it's like an ancillary product
it's not like the thing for us it was
the thing I'm coming over to your house
cuz you have a better high five sister
than I do
so I'm gonna listen to my new record at
your house because you have [ __ ] and
[ __ ] we're gonna smoke pot we're gonna
listen to the [ __ ] news up suppling
record now it's like let's go over to
his house because he's got a better play
station he's got surround sound
PlayStation ever thought about this you
know I've never thought about if we
could get another piece of product that
required a way of listening to things
again like 5.1 surround sound if that
became cool again which it should
because I've heard records done in 5.1
surround and it's [ __ ] phenomenal I
heard a remix of like Oh Blackwater you
know in 5.1 and voices are over and it
was incredible just fricking incredible
nobody cares they're fine with this
compressed sound that comes off of a of
laptop you know with headphones so let
me ask you a fake bass plays 800 for
Rolling Stone tickets is it 29 year old
kids that go to Lola not Lollapalooza
what's the one in the desert that they
paid 250 for ticket lad
jail and it was just in the desert yeah
what's the one not brilliant not burning
nobody paceman it's the big one Beyonce
just in it Oh
Coachella yeah okay so Coachella's young
kids that's primarily 30 okay now who's
gonna pay 800 to go see the stones guys
our age or will there be like I was
talking to the owner of the Nashville
zany's and he's a [ __ ] dead end to
the end you know now he gotta cut his
hair and the whole thing but he has all
stories for hours and he said that last
year two years ago as a joke he fretted
he went to see him in Denver and he said
that he had to leave he goes it wasn't
really Bennett's it was kids we'd done
had t-shirts on smoking pot well you
know what this that can happen you know
what I mean it can be a lot of people no
no there's a smaller thing right but
people rediscover things I mean the
thing is is that so many of these bands
were a moment in time I mean you know
Rolling Stones are a phenomenon I mean
if you die affect each guy's playing you
know is you know people better guitar
players and Keith Richards I know all
this stuff is subjective okay but I mean
from a technical standpoint a lot of
people are gonna be better guitar
players in Keith Richards but Keith
Richards somehow has that grease and the
stones together feel like they're gonna
fall off the edge all the time you
always like there's this uneasiness it's
not that the imperfection is what's so
perfect about them I mean it just feels
like it's gonna fall apart and it
doesn't fall apart it stays together but
barely and you're waiting for the next
one you know what I mean there's this
tension in their music you know and it's
like sometimes you know Ron's like you
know even on stage he's like he's
telling you know mix something you know
what I mean like there's this crazy
exchange and not every band works that
way some bands it's like their plan to a
click and they're just all doing their
thing and it's a great song and the
vocals are on
musics on and okay great so how do you
come up with a band like the stone even
even there even Zeppelin if you think
about it as good a players as they were
the way they mash is really what it what
makes it work what made that band work
you know any man just I mean sometimes
you know the bottom would be planned in
a different time than Paige would be
playing it and it would sound like it
was in the same time but it would create
this tension but we do it with poison
CeCe's ahead of the beat and I sit
behind the beat that's just how it's
always been
and there's this thing and if I play
with a different guitar player it's
bitchin and a lot of times were right on
but there's something between CC and I
that works and most drummers and guitar
players don't work that way it's usually
bass players and drummers that have that
dynamic you know Bobby's always right up
the middle glues it together you know
and that's what makes it work for us you
know with all the components to make a
great band like it's just not for great
musicians there's so many it's invisible
jiu jitsu do exactly if one plus one
equal to we'd be doing it all available
all day long this morning I listen to
what I think is a musical masterpiece it
was a noun that I just saw sunk into my
head a weird time in my life well that
was just starting to discover who the
[ __ ] I was and experiment that just
happened for me like a year ago
I listened to some girls Oh on the plane
today I have to finish start to finish
and the one thing I say about it was
Keith I think Keith's guitar work on it
on some girls just for song some girls
is phenomenal respectable beast of
burden that song us I love that so many
[ __ ] great beasts of burden just
destroys the audience that destroys it's
emotional I mean it's you know the
emotion in their stuff is what I mean
that they I heard that the way they
record and I don't know this to be true
but they'll just do one part over and
over and over again until it feels right
and then they'll splice that and then
they'll do the next part over and over
and get toefield kind of like pro
tooling but they did it with splicing
tape organically for years and years
like that I don't know if it's true or
not but but they're looking for that
moment you know when we worked when we
worked with when we did the
flesh-and-blood record that's how it was
the producer God rest his soul
wanted he only wanted three takes out of
me and if I didn't get it in three tapes
he's like we're moving on to the next
song we'll deal with it either next day
or after lunch at the end of the day but
I want a snapshot
I want the inspired performance within
within Bruce Fairburn I for some reason
I forgot his name for a second I want
you know he just wanted that that
initial feeling within the first three
takes I think I did four takes on one
song and if I didn't get it but we'll do
it tomorrow I want it inspired I want it
to feel fresh and inspired and I'll feel
it I'll know it when I hear it you know
what I mean I couldn't even hear it
anymore you know we rehearse the [ __ ] so
many times I didn't know when I was
inspired and when I wasn't anymore
that's why you need an adult in the room
when you're a kid were eight making a
record now I think I recognize it but I
probably still don't you like the
recording process I do I love the
recording process I love the live
process I love every piece of making
music I like the writing all of it I
don't like the business part I'm not a
good business guy that's why I let Bobby
doll do it I'm not a good business
person I just don't like that part I
don't like looking at somebody and say
Tom you need pay me this much it sucks
yeah I don't know sucks dick it does
this club I'm doing this weekend I'm
doing whoa-ho this weekend lo haría
seats under name nine tickets maybe one
90 maybe one 95
most comics avoid it because they can't
make any money in now I wanted to do it
because it's the way calmly was meant to
be done you know I love comics I love
chameleons with all my heart I love the
but I think at one time a venue you lose
that magic you know like when Mitzi sure
opened up the boy Tommy store 490 seats
she was Jewish really happy sure then do
she paid $15 a set she could have put
400 seats in there she wanted to but she
didn't she like the intimacy of that
place you know and it's so weird that
that's what it was meant to be in the
beginning and now it's become Madison
Square Garden I mean yeah my favorite
did [ __ ] the one place in the city
Lenny Bruce yeah at Carnegie Hall
I get that I get but it's got to be the
perfect venue big Lenny Brewster I was a
bigger Pryor fan yeah
but Lenny has something I really dig I
really like to tap into well I was into
Lenny Bruce it makes me I don't know he
had some balls he had balls he makes me
go crazy he makes me go crazy his Jewish
dancing like his Jew it I could feel a
Jew come in the room the might of the
album uh-huh which isn't even meant to
be funny enough and Happy Hanukkah all
the Jews up this was just something
about him
he wasn't soft you like he was a tough
Jew and he [ __ ] something just about
him he was always one step you yeah past
everybody else is thinking what I read
and when people would catch up to him
they go ah yeah that's why it was so I
love when I when I read that book it
changed me as the first time I read that
book I knew I wasn't [ __ ] crazy
Freddie Prinze yeah
did he mean anything Freddie Prinze
absolutely because he was Spanish yeah
so Freddie Prinze came along you know I
was trying to get Freddie Prinze Freddie
Prinze jr. does the show with a dear
friend of mine and we were trying to get
Freddie on here and I think I'm happy we
couldn't get it together because I think
it'd be too emotional for a guy like me
oh yeah because it's very it's very
rough explain what happened it was 1970
you know and I was a kid and I was
learning the language and then I fell in
love with all these different people and
the first guy fall in love with it was
Roberto Clemente of course you know I
loved your rose [ __ ] Pete Rose was my
[ __ ] when I was growing up when
I saw that guy could you know that who
says ADHD people oh here's what ADHD
he's got a lot of pride he's been all
but he's been out yeah gambling things
that's what that's what that may have
caused some stuff as it right yeah but
uh you know I had all these heroes you
know Julius Erving but there was
something about Roberto Clemente's death
that that it was just New Year's Day
yeah yeah so he is day like you know New
Year's Day this guy had just [ __ ] hit
is to be hundred hit like this guy was
on fire like an almost sudden there's an
earthquake and he's gonna bring me
supplies down he's gonna be a good guy
to Nicaragua and the plane disappears
and [ __ ] the Bermuda Triangle it just
destroyed America just like people were
like why man it's it's it's it's a deep
story
beep-beep like you like this is
America's baseball and he was [ __ ]
Puerto Rican but if you watch his videos
his English you could feel his English
how it came through like he really
wanted to be an American you always have
a little suit on
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] he was just a badass
leave [ __ ] if he played the Red Sox
you still cheered for he was that type
of guy like you know you know what man I
the Pittsburgh pies and the Dodgers had
really like the whole story is the
Dodgers had them and they didn't know
what to do and then he went to [ __ ]
Pittsburgh and it's just I forgot that
you're from Pennsylvania and you grew up
in it you know that that catcher never
recovered
many same game like never recovered like
that was his [ __ ] best friend yeah
they were both Porto Ricans he went down
to the [ __ ] keys and sat on the beach
waiting for a burger walk out of the
water
that's how man he was like Roberto with
such but such a badass I had to fly down
there just to see if he would walk out
of the ocean like that's how [ __ ] and
then after he died no the whole thing's
an intense story that's like very very
you know Jay Bishop Jay bish he's a
Pittsburgh guy he's he sends me all my
Pittsburgh style huh huh the Bronson
shirt yeah I got two nice shirts that he
said to me he just gave me a poster from
the Roberto Clemente Museum nice when I
go home and you said I'm gonna give it
to my brother friend bring it here
so after he dies he's Porto Rican
Freddie Prinze comes along you know and
America was taking a [ __ ] beating
that then then Freddie Prinze shoots
himself you know which is like you know
this comedian the [ __ ] world
yeah that was a weird dude some service
a weird no and I had no ya know anything
for the rest of the world came out of
nowhere
no internet you [ __ ] walking home but
I was walking I'm on a Friday night
I still remember being with my friends
and somebody going Freddie Prinze shot
himself we didn't know them like I had
walked through a cemetery I think that
night that was the magnates and girls
[ __ ] [ __ ] behind the grammar school
I still remember a day I [ __ ] the
first I hate a [ __ ] and [ __ ] he's
supposed to do anyway I know it was
freezing outside he was a year older to
be this many drugs having this no no
[Music]
this was a different girl this is a
German girl the barricaded space hated
Spanish beat hey we'll listen go back to
desi arnaz
I may not have it you know come on well
does he you know desi I loved and the
whole thing and he related to what once
Freddie Prinze shot himself that's so
that's more our era till then and then
I'll tell you what destroyed me the one
that put the [ __ ] straw on the
camel's back with Bruce Lee that was it
[ __ ] that [ __ ] me up for three or
four months I went nuts for three or
four months you know I just I just saw
Danny and Asano yeah we hope that they
will know I just saw him I took a
picture with him my son was with me I
was what two weeks ago and what's the 80
something I mean you know any trains
every day he is Yoda he is the living
Yoda of our generation
I mean he's learned more martial arts
he's forgotten more martial arts to now
ever learn I mean yeah I mean the guy's
amazing
I took even one of the first things I
wanted to learn was JKD because of Bruce
Lee and so when I had the money and the
time finally I dedicated myself and I
hired cast Magda who was Danny's protege
for a long time and Danny was Bruce's
protege so I'm like well [ __ ] this makes
me like third-generation Bruce Lee kind
of you know what I mean and I worked
with him for five years and I learned
JKD and I learned Kali
you know the stick fighting and the
knife fighting and see lot and I that's
where the ground stuff started to come
in which connected me back in high
school with the wrestling when I
wrestled in school and so when I met the
Machado brother so I was like that's
what really sunk in to me I realized
that I'm a ground game guy what Ziva
well see there's a supposed that's my
l8e yes thanks a lot which is I've heard
that there's like hundreds of styles
because there's hundreds of villages
okay but the one one of a
words you know and like Sumatra that's
so wet you know so they just started the
ground because we're gonna fall down so
they just start there and that's one of
the kind some of it looks like bad kung
fu' I mean so if it's not good and some
of it's extremely effective stuff you
know and I mean it's a loose grappling
style and there's strikes but it's more
you know trips and get the guy on the
ground and sometimes there's weapons
involved it just depends on the style of
cela there's just a couple of a hundred
and fourty styles or some crazy and
[ __ ] number and some are more
prominent than others I met I remember
meeting some people from Indonesia and
guy came into a jujitsu school and I'm
like did you ever study see lot and he
goes no there's Taekwondo schools on
like every corner like a good thing I'm
not going over there I can learn more of
it here because yeah you probably could
what's G Kudo like like I never I think
that very simply so much that I didn't
even wanna even [ __ ] with you know I
gotta tell you it was when when Bruce
was you know I mean it initially it came
from Wing Chun Kung Fu and I think when
he came over here he realized that
American Western boxing was such an
alive art that you know because it's
when he said you know like if you can if
you can look you know box for a year and
wrestle for a year you can probably beat
every lifetime martial artist you know
because he realized how effective those
things really truly were so he started
to combine the boxing and the Wing Chun
Kung Fu together and I think it just
started and he started to look at other
martial arts and go this is why this
works and this is why it doesn't and why
are people practicing and learning
techniques that don't work in real
combat what the hell are you doing this
for and he would verbalize this and he
would piss people off man he made a lot
of [ __ ] people mad and he was just
being truthful he's just gone you need
this do you you have to listen to your
instincts too
you can't just a hundred percent take
somebody else's word for it
hey if I'd you know if I hit this person
in the solar plexus it's going to crush
this and they're gonna fall down and
they're gonna die well if that worked
it'd be happening in the UFC yeah you
nee mean but so I think what he did was
just put a lens on it hey you know Cass
told me that you know you can actually
learn JKD in like three months the
principles you know the punches just you
know the strikes to kick store not it's
not complicated it just takes a long
time to get really good at it it's just
like muy Thai there's not a ton of
punches and kicks and like bruce lee
said you know when you first learn
martial arts that punches a punch and
when you've gotten to black belt a punch
is still just a punch you know and i
mean it's it at the end of the day it's
like you know all this
physics belongs to all of us you know
and none of us are born with four arms
and you know so it's not a complicated
art it's it's not at all it's very
simple you just it just takes a long
time I think to hone it to where you're
really good at it it's just like drums I
can hit a drum make a noise you're gonna
hit a drum and make it know it but to
make the Nori's cohesive into something
that sounds like a piece of music that
takes a little time and that's what JKD
is it's putting all those pieces
together until no forms right don't fall
no there's no form so it's they used to
you know sometimes people teach with the
wooden dummy I know Danny did I've never
studied under Danny so I'm not sure but
from what I've heard and but cast didn't
do the wooden dummy he didn't teach with
that the wooden dummy is the Wing Chun
yeah with the two little arms
yeah stationary okay and just keep
making little blocks at your hands and
using Michael penny elbows on maybe not
it's a lot of trapping and stuff like
that but you know I think that I mean
look if that trapping work that well I
think boxers would use it and I think
boxers have their own little version of
trapping
but that the way they trap in in Wing
Chun I not that it can't be effective
anything delivered at the right time can
be effective I remember in the UFC the
early days everybody said you know what
why even bother kicking you do a high
kick you're gonna get you're gonna get
knocked out somebody's gonna take you
down and that's the end of it so just
forget ever learning high kicks
well now you're looking at people using
high kicks and their work and because
they know when to deliver it even heard
of mean if somebody's trying takedowns
for the first two rounds they're gonna
start getting tired and their takedowns
aren't gonna be effective that's the
time to use a high kick on a guy he
comes in for that takedown I mean we saw
that hop play out many times in the UFC
I don't remember what fight it was but
it's crazy how that [ __ ] works you know
Bruce Lee was alive today I think he'd
be all over the UFC I think it'd be a
commentator you know what I mean I glory
Ascan you imagine that I don't know I
don't know I don't know how I would feel
cause that first I didn't like it at
first the UFC when I turned around I saw
two fat guys I was furious
really when what would you have see
versus you know I just won his first
star one of the first one like that was
such a purist like you know when I quit
martial arts I quit and there was
another thing like it was like the first
time I had to walk away from it
not because I was lazy I was scared
because I had to choosing my lifestyle
where I had to go train at fifteen was
two bus rides and those kids didn't do
what I liked doing at that age I want to
go get [ __ ] they wanted to Train on
Saturdays and Saturday might stay in and
watch [ __ ] kung fu movies and
practice the iron palm technique in
their basements and [ __ ] I didn't want
to do that I wanted to get high and get
my dick sucked it wasn't happening well
but that series what you were trying and
they weren't getting an iron fist either
that was staying in we want karate from
9:00 in the morning to [ __ ] one then
we go eat pizza
and Union City and then we'd walk down
Burt you know it was a gonna all day
[ __ ] a fad right he Kunis and
sometimes they got together at night at
our panic to drop us off and we watch
colorful movies or something like that
this is the thing I mean it's it's we
you know if you look at the movies that
come out and even like Jackie Chan and I
happen to love Jackie Chan I love kung
fu movies and all that stuff I think
it's great but at the end of the day I
mean what is truth what is the truth and
I think Bruce Lee was constantly
searching for the truth what really
works but at the same time he was making
movies that were far-fetched you know
any man and he knew that he was doing
things in those movies that probably
wouldn't work in real life but he would
talk about the truth you know and a man
so what he would preach and what he
would put in a movie were two different
things
you know and I mean they were not the
same God one guy was an actor and one
guy was a serious martial artist that
serious martial artist is the guy that I
really found the most intriguing but you
know what is the truth with you know
anything can any you know you heard the
old saying any horse can win on any day
I mean you know some pure karate guy
old-school karate guy could walk into
the UFC and win you don't [ __ ] know
probably not you know what I mean I mean
the the hybrid of of is almost it almost
have to have that hybrid thing today
that's what blows my mind about Demian
Maia though and you know about Demian
Maia he's one of the few guys that I
mean I don't know how much stand-up he
trained or where he trained his stand-up
not a ton of it I don't think he's one
of these guys that I mean just these
like a John jock or any jujitsu guy with
almost pure jujitsu is come in and rank
what up to four or five in the UFC you
know he hasn't fought in a while he's
getting older now he's got a little
amazing I saw I saw his hands get
improve let but they never really
matched but it's one of the few martial
arts that still holds up even today in
that kind of an environment is brazilian
jiu zhai that's I uh I am very
impressive you still have to learn how
to impress and you know what there is
more ground than pound I watched fight
night last night there was so much
grappling and ground and pound there for
a while I was seeing so much stand up
stand up stand up stand up on Maidan it
looks like k1 kickboxing this isn't as
interesting to me then all the sudden
little by little you know and I think
khabib assured that in a little more you
know I mean the guy that has like one of
the best records in UFC history was
grounded in pound and it's like he you
know he's got something right here you
know what do you think of or why do you
think there there aren't as many martial
arts movies anymore like in the 80s or
whatever there was jarred clunk Van
Damme
there was a I'm blanking on his name
right now but the guy who's kind of
rushed and he goes to Russia he still
makes movies they're not that great
whatever it is well you're gonna answer
this so UFC right yeah but I mean you
know there was still I mean there was
action movies back in the 80s or there
was Rambo and all that stuff yeah and
they Billy Jack was on oh I'm gonna put
this leg on that side there he could be
a [ __ ] lady you could do about 1970
they took a deep [ __ ] chance of Billy
Jack and they won yeah had them until
they took him to trial the trial of
Billy Jack was me yeah you know who did
the soundtrack oh coven a band that had
a 12-minute Black Sabbath literally on
their record it was on a record called
blood on the snow and the lead singer is
a girl named jinx
I don't ask me why I notice my mind is a
fricken junkie oh I love it I love
there's a lot of people even know Billy
Jack was I forgot it until and he was
fighting for the Indians
for the unions that's what that was all
it was like 1969 you know Bruce Lee's
already out people already know about
Bruce Lee America said we got to get a
jump on this we can't let this get out
of control we could novel a little Asian
man
so they trained this guy that was an
ex-marine yeah white dude that he was a
badass was he Indian at all he is
supposed to be if he if he did 23 of me
fellas if we did 22 in me I think he
failed a test I think I forgot see what
the guy's name was and what's the if you
don't mind Lee please if they give you
any background for the guy he was just a
white dude and he fought for them Indian
and Lee
it [ __ ] skyrocketed but born losers
wasn't that the second one was that a
different type it was it was Billy Jack
and then it ends with him going to jail
one loser was the first one born loser
was the first one okay all right
I know I'm not totally yeah yes so what
years well I saw it at the drive-ins
yeah I saw either the driving to one
Clifton New Jersey often I saw it you
know into like Carlisle Pierre so what's
the score the Pittsburgh game hit me
baby
well Billy Jack was in 71 right that's
and that's two years before Enter the
Dragon
right around Chinese connection type so
it was ballsy to release whoo 723 to 7
Steelers I love it it's at the half
though there's still some football to be
played and the the guy who know a Billy
Jack wrote it and directed it what was
his name Tom laughs ones are lawfully
yeah I got a friend named timeloss yeah
yeah crazy huh
let me see let me find out if he was
really Native American yeah that guy was
the [ __ ] one name I watched that movie
the other and I liked it put a big smile
now hey did you like biker movies
because I loved biker movies when I was
giving example Hells Angels 60
and all that stuff but then Joe Namath
was in see see rider and William Smith
was always in all those movies that
always a tough guy and it was also in
Sonoma
CC that's it that's it right there I
said see ok I love it
but what's up with Joe Namath doing
these commercials well he sounds like
he's from New Orleans where is he from
well I thought it was a New York guy
right Joe Namath has gone through a lot
of changes leave John Damien well that's
a lot for at the end you see at the end
before he died that poor bastard from
Mary he died no no no man that poor
bastard American Bandstand what was his
name
oh yeah yeah Dick Clark the last
couldn't believe they put him one way in
a stroke didn't he his head was all
[ __ ] up the show like this so yeah and
you know what I do want to do a quick
little shout-out to on to a Kenny bond
by the way I'm sure you heard about that
No one of our jujitsu guys battled brain
cancer for two couple years
see if somebody finally passed away a
couple days ago and just I mean every
every street sports school were just all
in mourning about it he was such an
awesome dude and you know so I know
Nadine his wife and you know he's got
the dick to kids and stuff like that and
they do I think I put up on my Facebook
page a link to the for a support page
that what do you call it a go fund me go
fund me so I hope I hope people will
definitely contribute because I'll share
you know he it is you know yeah I was
really devastated about that he was a
Native American told you he wasn't no no
okay no he just sold it he said he wore
the Hat yeah he put the Hat on and he
just spoke this it was what a weird time
in America what a weird I was a kid and
I remember how like that was it America
was back mantra he was like Trump in
1970 like America was back he was ready
to go like that
pagon
back we were coming back from Vietnam we
got Billy Jack now yeah Billy Jack was
yeah he was that was a badass movie
there was there were so many cool movies
back then I think I mean I just maybe it
was just cuz I'm so young it's just
everything was amazing me and I still
have a commercial for the French
Connection yes
[ __ ] yeah my dad took me to see him my
mom said no you're not going to see it
my dad took me anyway I have a goal I
see that the movie theater but the
commercial said filmed in New York where
it happened he's walking running up the
stairs and wasn't that the first
high-speed auto change yeah together
some pretty famous for editing it's the
first uh that's the first ever yeah it's
pretty cool I saw that at MoMA in New
York oh did you yeah they were screening
it was fun it was great always they
that's the first time that you know how
they were he chased him underneath the
subway yeah no that was the first time
they ever shot a scene like that really
yeah that was the first one yeah and
then and of course Steve McQueen did
stuff later and yeah Steve McQueen took
it up a notch you so did [ __ ] Burt
Reynolds no longest shot hell yeah I did
what I want whatever the [ __ ] car he
was yeah that's why I'm really in shock
that that was the first big car scene
that's crazy French Connection was what
year though that was like 68 Eaters I
mean 69 something like that oh hey we
should play Trivial 7171 okay tell you
the reason I don't wait to see this that
movie you're not gonna believe but I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell people at
home anyway okay there's a writer called
PJ what was his name that we brought him
on the English TJ English is a writer
out of New York and he's uh he's Irish
got it and he wrote a book about the
Westies and then he wrote two books
about Cuban culture and they both
Westies were bad ass [ __ ] bad I know
about us then he wrote two books that
one's getting done as a TV 10 part mini
series on HBO was that good
and the other one is called whatever the
[ __ ] the one that we had them on there
for but in that book he had a bunch of
names of people I grew up around you
know and and I when he was right in the
book I contacted him and he interviewed
me on a lot of the people a couple weeks
ago I was thinking about the French
Connection and I know but I called him
up like Oh class your question and any
of your files did you read a man of a
guy named Louie ababil and Cuban that
means Lewis the turkey that was his name
Louie about so when I was a kid the
reason why I went to see the French
Connection is cuz my mother pulled me
aside and she goes come and go watch the
French Connection and see if they have
mentioned Lewis de pavo if they don't
mention the movies of fate did energon
know but what I told him well I talked
to TJ English that time the first time
he said no but let me look through my
stuff about six weeks later he called
back and he goes this guy this Lewis the
power was never really mentioned but he
was one of the original guys that was
putting the coke on the cars and he had
a heroin and now they were waiting it
that's how they were they would put it
in the car and ship it from France in
the United States and they would weigh
the car so you would have to take
something out of the car because they
knew the weights of the car yeah they do
the weight to the car how big thing like
you know which we well what movie were
we watching
oh come on the one with Marky Wahlberg
when they were chasing the Diamonds of
the gold around town Italian John and
they could tell by the measurement on
the tires if the weight yeah you know oh
yeah they'll cut the tire right open and
[ __ ] cuz that's you know coming
across the border I'm gonna use the
restroom go go one time just a quick
potty break I'll be waiting dad we're
gonna read the [ __ ] that real quick
while I have you here while mr. Ricky
rock is taking a little breather I'd
like to talk to you people buy a little
something
on it is always their fear they're there
with supplements they're there with
kettlebells that ever whatever you need
them they got it
this morning before I got on the plane
what you think I did you think I [ __ ]
yeah I smoked a joint what else we'll
took two shroom try communes because I
don't know who's sitting next no volley
bob is sitting next to me what John
[ __ ] Smith but I don't want to take a
chance because god knows what the [ __ ]
they're breathing it's trust either I
don't trust nobody
so when you fly and always remember to
go with shroom tech why do you ask
because well they ain't gonna be that
one there they gonna be this you know
waving at me that's the worst part is
before go wait and I could not believe
it was so [ __ ] bad yeah I was hoping
that Ricky rocket didn't sniffing oh
this will never be a guest on this show
on Kennedy caught a whiff of this wait
thank you for sharing it with me you go
to airplane parts why are you standing
up now oh he's airing it out this is
this is the same person who farted so
bad they need to take a shower after
your last and stop waving it at my god
damnit see you can never leave again
right farting the entire time oh god I
can't even breathe out
sorry doc how impressed Church and get
10% off your order alright she'll take
for it she'll check a minute so talk to
me what possessed you what possesses a
man to wake up one morning and say you
know what I'm a black belt in jujitsu I
I've sold millions of [ __ ] records
with a band you know millions worldwide
I'm gonna wake up and open up a coffee
company
talk to me you know what we were talking
about this earlier
my buddy garrison the head of A&R for
drum workshop and we started rows with
such coffee fanatics that we started to
get we bought a little roaster we're
like let's buy some beans and it's just
[ __ ] rose
you know so we're doing it in the garage
on Sunday afternoons right watching TV
and then we go where to do a podcast and
have drummers on the show since you work
for drum workshop and I'm a drummer but
the rule is that we can't talk about
drums we just talk about everything else
so we thought it was a great [ __ ]
idea and then he moved unfortunately so
couple years later when I met my girl we
talked about coffee she was a big coffee
connoisseur we just decided to do it
when she was modeling she went by TC TNT
bombs and I'm Rockets so that's why it's
bombs and rockets now when you talk
about a big connoisseur of coffee when
she talks she talks to you about a rock
makanda bean you should like that she
[ __ ] beans to me bro tell you
something it's odd but like that's
people I have I've had discussions with
people that know [ __ ] about coffee that
has blown me the [ __ ] away you know what
it's just about taste for me literally
you know any man
I mean it's is if it tastes good it's
good you know I mean have you have you
tried the really expensive one whether
like an animal eats the bean and poops
it out I just saw a video about it it's
crazy
it's like a hundred doors like really
expensive coffee per cup now I'm looking
at top models eating orders and pooping
it out and then we make it into that
that's that's the way this is telling
you you might want to try it I just I
heard about a beer somebody doing that
with vaginal juices and making it into
beer and Europe or something like that
I don't know drink that [ __ ] yeah my
face Kopi Luwak it's the world's most
expensive coffee let me just see how
much it costs but what's the what's the
water catch that it's like a Catholic
animal and from what I read they were
when I saw on the thing and said they
think that the the animal chooses like
the best beans and if there's some sort
of like what animal it's called a Kopi
Luwak it's like it's kind of you can't
that's what they said Oh welcome people
listen the Colombians be drinking coffee
making you jumping up and down for 2,000
years now they want to show up
[ __ ] a cat that eats are being so
cost 35 to $100 per cup well listen we
just wanted to make a really good cup of
coffee
not reinvent the wheel you know it's so
great you know eats the bean and shits
it out and I'm gonna [ __ ] cook that
up at the house you might as well smell
my oh my farts for free I hate how much
would you charge for that I hate people
[ __ ] two hours this lift I hate when
people really do try and reinvent the
wheel especially to a guy like me like
I'm CUBAN I love coffee the only reason
why I don't have diabetes is because I
avoid the Cuban style coffee
why what's different is your sugar it's
I have some coffee with you should oh is
that it yeah you know I love goals I
know how the Turks do it right leg rings
I love going to Miami International
Airport once every two years and looking
at Starbucks it's a [ __ ] ghost town
you'd have to be an idiot to go into
Starbucks in my hair
no yeah like if you go into a Starbucks
in Miami walk out and shoot you
something cuz that's the best thing you
could do for your life hey man you know
what every any city I go into that's one
of the things and I love Starbucks
Starbucks I love peeps
whatever that is Pete Pete Speedy's I
love them all what I'm trying to say to
you is in in Miami for a dollar fifty
they give you a white cup that has six
shots of Express on Cuban stop that you
get gets hard
the hairs where your bald over here you
can feel navigating and saying you
snorted a black beauty in the 70s you
can feel your hair moving your scalp I
swear to God give me some of that [ __ ]
now run home yes no no so a lot of
people that's what I'm saying when you
go to Miami International Airport you
look at like the Cuban restaurant there
there's a live for [ __ ] coffee you
look at the Starbucks it's a one-person
operation I swear to God is your wife
Cuban No
my wife is in Tennessee what we learned
how to make Cuban coffee
they don't have Cubans in Tennessee
Cuban food in Tennessee the problem is
the Cubans the cute how bad how good is
that sticking around that's the way most
farts dissipate this is just hanging on
the air this is just like it's like
painted orange or something this is it
just got you in the corner like Muhammad
Ali had Joe Frazier was 71 in the corner
he's just got Joe Vitt he broke the
building I told you you've done good
that's direct fulfilled yeah when did
you get back last night
this morning oh this morning I had two
shows I came here just for he came here
just for me who shows Friday one
Thursday you know it's so funny
if when you were 20 how are we when you
started poison when you got involved
with boys that started like 91 did you
think that at 55 you were still gonna be
in demand to go on the road no no [ __ ]
no no so you know I mean look at that
compressor bands that are going on the
road now these ages if the stones go on
the road what's the average age of the
stones 70 what's going on anyway it's
Keith what's Rumer yeah Keith net that's
it and met Charlie Watts and no one and
uh Ron Wood oh that's right yeah I got
Ronnie from the phases where he's been
with them for what 20 some you 30 years
yeah so they're all their self and Mick
was amazing with Junko yeah I mean [ __ ]
I mean there were the stones I mean what
are you doing all of their seventies I'm
trying to think so and they gotta go on
the road and [ __ ] perform every other
day Mick Jagger's gonna tear that [ __ ]
up
he's gonna [ __ ] inspire another you
know decade of young rockers like he
always has you know and Tina Turner
inspired him so what are you gonna do
you're gonna go you gotta pay the 800
you got a lot of choice yeah I gotta go
I'm gonna just go by myself though cuz I
don't want to pay for anybody else
I'm gonna take my man no I'm nobody [ __ ]
everybody no I'm alright no my girl and
I will go and not wants to go
you must take his wife and hopefully
it'll work out I already have a call
into management nobody's calling me back
you know why cuz poisoning on the road
right now so nobody I can't I can't
barter [ __ ] right now you know it's so
weird you know it's like you know I was
talking about this the other day one
platform to another doesn't equate okay
like like we like we're so lucky Orban
okay I feel so privileged to be able to
be in this band and go out on the road
and play for 10 12 14 15 thousand people
a night I mean we're very lucky to be
able to do that at this point and our
knows well if we're still doing that
kind of business while some nights
they'll be an 8,000 seater some nights
you'll be a 15 but on average it's 10 in
there ok that's pretty awesome and
that's a headlining thing because we
headline this last time but I go on I
have a YouTube channel and it's really
hard to grow that channel very very hard
hard as [ __ ] I didn't realize how hard
that would be what's on your youtube
channel I do mainly vlogs that have to
do with motorcycle stuff and or at least
motorcycles are always the backdrop even
if I do I did one day I didn't even mean
to do it
I got a BBQ girl and the thing was
totally [ __ ] up when I got it so I did
a vlog about taking it back and
assembling a BBQ grill but in the middle
of it I get frustrated and take a ride
the motorcycle and I do this whole thing
where I have like GoPro cameras and all
the stuff I always wind up doing
something with a motorcycle almost nine
times out of ten however I just did this
one little mystery thing that I did for
Halloween and a old friend of mine that
did all the documentaries for a medieval
called me up and he said hey man we got
to do something together do you have any
other stuff and I said yes I do I'm
sitting along really really good mystery
right now that is absolutely one of the
most demand I'm not going to tell
anybody right now because if I do
somebody will steal a [ __ ] idea but
it's something that happened in another
state 40 years ago and him and I are
going to do something on it and
hopefully it'll wind up on a TV show
that would be pretty cool but I want to
ride my motorcycle to it I don't want to
just show up on here I didn't know you
were a big biker guy oh I have eight
motorcycles I have eight motorcycles and
about a dozen mini bikes I'm out of my
mind I've had 15 motorcycles at one time
I love mini bikes with my mini bike days
are over
like I call myself the motorcycle
evangelist I would love to go do writing
again I just did it this weekend I took
the kids I would love and then last
weekend we went out to the desert Lucy
my five-year-olds riding jude's quad and
Jude has a 110 Kawasaki he's riding a
dirt bike now I have a 250 and we just
all ride together we go slow you know
other kids and but to him he's hauling
ass I mean he's doing good she's doing
good it's so much fun they get dirty and
front love you know do you ride poker is
it do you ride motorcycles on the street
- oh yeah oh that's that's what I did
I did a vlog okay this is one thing I
did over the summer ctc my girlfriend
her colons got to come out later this
year or early next year rather she's got
a very rare condition that she just has
to have it removed her she'll get cancer
I beat cancer
at least so far I think I'm I'm good so
yeah exactly so we said we want to do
Sturgis I want to go to Sturgis so what
does we flew into Sturgis bought an
Indian Roadmaster wrote it back to LA
and hit like nine I think it was nine
national parks we took like two weeks to
go and hang out ride around and just
have a good time and I did a vlog series
about I think I did like six or seven
and eight eight installments is what it
was awesome
and I was just watching it like
yesterday I was like I was reliving it
all over again it was so awesome I have
my girl on the back of the motorcycle
and we just [ __ ] did we I think we
wound up doing like 20 20 800 miles
almost 3,000 miles on the bike over a
period of two weeks I mean we just
[ __ ] rode and rode and rode it was
awesome gotta do it man I want to do it
again but I don't know I don't think
she's gonna be able to do it yeah your
photo I have it brother you really it
does that with you and it got hot holy
[ __ ] it was a hundred and fourteen
degrees going through Nevada yeah that's
a nightmare that's a [ __ ] nightmare
bugs hit you we had these shirts on that
we'd get wet put them on and then these
cooling vest we'd get wet and put those
on I mean we're just soaking wet
ourselves down and just go like 45
minutes until everything completely
evaporated then we pull over to another
gas station get everything all wet again
and take off again that's how we did
that one day where was I hardly even
vlog because it was I didn't want to
[ __ ] pull camera out so hot miserable
I just wanted to get to where we were
going but the rest of it was like chill
I mean it was you know an amazing
experience and she planned everything
out otherwise I would have been sleeping
alongside the road somewhere because I
hadn't planned [ __ ] she planned
everything we stated all these Airbnb
Zand you know stuff like that
bingo crappy hotels what's that this
[ __ ] guy always gets a rash of there
being oh I got a you know why I got a I
got some [ __ ] serious monkey butt
though on that right yeah oh [ __ ] yeah
and we talked about it too we put so
much powder on there was Pat Lee look
like [ __ ] Charlie Sheen out of party
I mean there was power [ __ ]
everywhere in this hotel room I'm like
oh we can't leave it like this right I
had poison at a party in here
ride motorcycles as a kid
oh yeah hell yeah I [ __ ] I'm thinking
about it now I've been thinking about it
for the last year but I just don't know
where to go
like I don't want to have to [ __ ]
haul my bike I like to live somewhere
that's why I wanted to move somewhere
where I could just have my bike you know
drive it maybe a mile on the offroad and
then also you want a dirt ride yes I
don't you got to get an enduro I mean a
plated but I mean that nowadays excuse
me
nowadays some of the enduros like that
[ __ ] new KTM six days and 450 or
whatever a [ __ ] thing as a race bike
with a plate on it I mean you can go
anywhere and you know adventure riding
is so big now like BMWs you know no
gs-12 hundreds you know I didn't go in
the dirt West Oh am I too big no I still
love my brother I went from a Honda mini
trail which I have to of mother you
still have I have two of them do they
have a clutch now or this no neither
another coke what's three three on the
tree that's it and then I went to a 75
and then I went to an Excel Haiti really
happy yeah and then I got an XL 125
Kawasaki had a place run up to corner
from me and it was I would be in there
every day tortured must be do you
understand me me and my buddies are
going in every day I had a Yamaha 60
that was my first motor seen Yamaha r6
he's a mini cycle now look like a
motorcycle but it was just little you
know any name kind of like what I got
for Jude look like that I had an Indian
for a while - no dude if you still had
that then you get those old Indian mini
bikes they're worth so much money it was
a college never sees it was only like a
hundred that's why I didn't got I only
had it for a short time they were never
good at at the dirt bike stuff back down
so much you know what I mean
neither was Harley Davidson they never
figured that out I was a cow is always
make I thought it would Honda and then I
went to a Kawasaki
then I had a Suzuki for a while one
something and I think I had an RM 125
grand I bought bikes and he bought a
Kawasaki and I bought a Suzuki they're
both we both bought 125 on one tour and
we compressed the [ __ ] forks as much
as we couldn't stick them under the bay
of the bus we just go right around the
parking lot try to find somewhere to go
off-roading try to get the bus driver to
drop us off somewhere oh we could we
were into it yeah that's what I want to
do again I really but no those into
enduros these days these four stroke
enduros what's the enduro that's a
different brand no no no and enduro is a
bike that it's a dual sport you can take
ride it in the street you can ride it in
the dirt you know and so if you you know
you could ride to where you know it's a
modern-day adventure bike you know any
man you're I have this philosophy that
your adventure shouldn't start at the
back of your truck it should start right
at your garage yeah I don't like then I
don't want to haul the [ __ ] thing
yeah that's my problem leave leave the
garage yeah and and so I try to keep
that in mind now when you have you know
full-on two-stroke dirt bikes I mean
that you know it is what it is but I'm
not a racer I'm not gonna race dirt
bikes at my age you know and [ __ ] I
just wanted to do 40 and just go on some
[ __ ] that's what I do now odd maybe
slipped in some mud I like that [ __ ]
yeah I just wash I got pictures of muddy
but I mean look at this shadow on the
model over the place I don't not trust
drivers whatsoever on the street I'm
done I'm done
I hear horror stories every day my heart
goes out to Wendy Liebman she got you're
gonna love this picture right here
that's my Kawasaki right there I just
Paul yeah
Kawasaki minutes the good times roll
yeah look about what sucks let the good
times roll that was the [ __ ] see what
that said quickest [ __ ]
[Laughter]
un-fuckin'-believable
[ __ ] believe but ya know these we you
know that's what my little girl rides
that's what my boy rides I've got it
this is [ __ ] was filthy when I brought
it home so let me ask you a question
before were podcasts were talking and
you were saying that you make the coffee
in New Jersey yes store this [ __ ] you
have everything going on well we were
gone we went TC and I went to a lot of
different sources to try to find
somebody that was reliable that because
we just we can't roast ourselves right
now we don't have a situation like that
and we wound up talking to various
people from various companies and most
of them a lot of them gave us some good
answers and then we wound up talking to
AC who was with Joan Jett for a long
time and now he's with the misfits and
he's doing dead sled coffee from the
same roaster and he said look let me
hook you up let's work together we can
do a bigger buy we can have to help each
other save money and so we've been
working with AC on it and so we did our
first order through those guys our
blends different than what they're doing
with dead sled but we're doing it
through the same roaster awesome people
by the way and so I want to fly back
there and go see these people soon talk
to him I want to do like a signature
like maybe like a different blend like
it seasonally like every season do
something different
little little something different maybe
a dark or a blonde or something
something that's not out there already
you know and I mean I want to experiment
with you like the darker coffees I do I
like strong car I like strong quality
that's what I mean I can draw I can
drink coffee right now and go to bed man
me too
you know I'm it's ridiculous I can love
it [ __ ] love it me too and I love it
I love strong strong strong
this isn't ridiculously strong it's a
good strong coffee but you know it's not
gonna it's not like you know it's not
like death wish or something
it's got a decent amount of caffeine but
you can you can drink a couple of cups
of it and you're not gonna be climbing
the walls
you got a website for it yeah well we do
I do everything through fallen angel
customs dotnet that's my my little
imprint is fallen it or any anything
that I do any kind of merge t-shirts
I've run it we run it all through that
so but yeah we have facebook page bombs
and rockets coffee but I saw everything
on fallen angel customs dotnet no man
Rambo to sell Rikki Rockett calm I have
a Rikki Rockett calm okay but it'll just
link you to following angel Cross Lanes
okay that's what I hope yeah what look
and how would I even know [ __ ] fallen
angel yeah we have that fallen angel one
of the plans I mean with all the money
that's getting thrown around to CC -
Romi some [ __ ] money this actually -
honors all of the other guys know does
this CC does not at this time what is he
doing between I mean he's he's got a son
he puts a lot of time into his boy and
you know he's semi-retired I mean he
just he's good with doing a you know
torn once a year for two three months
he's good with that
you know these guys it takes care of his
parents - they're not in the best of
health so he's taking care of his boy
he's taking care of his parents
is he here full-time he's an Orange
County okay yeah no he stayed oh you
don't have a place back east anymore no
he was in Philly for a little while he's
like how the [ __ ] did you guys move out
here and I wind up and but he's out here
yeah full-time you do you guys will tour
again next summer hopefully I don't
think so I think next summer it's gonna
be you know maybe some you know private
you know gigs like that and that's kind
of gonna be the extent of it so I'll be
focusing more on devil city angels for
next year and my you know my vlog and my
coffee and you know the little things
that I'm doing with that and just focus
on the kids you know
Aiki I never have a spare moment in the
day I swear to God a lot of people are
always like hey man are you just kicking
back I don't even what that [ __ ] one
I don't know what the [ __ ] it means I
clearly don't I don't understand that
people really get it like the level of
commitment that you have to put in I
think that a lot of people really do not
understand it's like when people call me
on Saturday nights when I'm doing comedy
nothing pisses me off more then when
people called me on Saturday nights like
constantly like like what the [ __ ] do
you think is it that I do why are you a
kid - yeah like oh I don't want to call
you too early because I know you're a
rock guy so you probably sleep and don't
want no I have kids are you kidding me
I'm the latest I get up at 6:30 a.m. a
little business and if I want to do
anything I gotta get up at 5:30 before
the kids get up or I'm not gonna be able
to get anything done people be like man
your post what do you have you [ __ ]
automatically post on Facebook no I'm up
I'm having my coffee my bombs and
rockets coffee and I'm posting [ __ ] and
because now the kids are up now I gotta
take care of them I gotta take him to
school I got to do all that stuff you
know this morning as I was boarding the
plane I was I bought it at 7:15 or some
holy [ __ ] would you go to the airport at
5:00 a.m.
uh-huh no the play was 755 and I had the
car pick me up at 6:15 okay watch I'm
cutting it close out there to quarters
oh that's funny where you at though what
Lauren no no but I mean how far you go
to 20 minutes oh okay well yeah you see
me I'm out the [ __ ] boondocks oh oh
no no I'm up by magic mount so for me to
get to the airborne oh I'm talking about
up in Portland
oh oh yeah yeah 20 minute ride I got
there I [ __ ] sat down I want two eggs
sunny-side up I always give myself
plenty of time if I can't hold a little
twig sunny-side up laying a nap I got a
little piece of wheat toast
the bacon I threw away the potatoes I
had some water I smoked a joint before
he got in the [ __ ] car with a cup of
coffee from the front I do it right I
got a download system no matter I love
breakfast
I love Prescott LeBron loved going to
break I'll have breakfast if I don't eat
my breakfast my day is [ __ ] wrong me2
I love those hotel buffets Oh
wake up you know why cuz I could eat you
know what the old ox is when you get in
late on the road and you miss breakfast
that sucks dick I want to punch all that
he wrote I mean I get up purposely I
meet you listen I'll go back to bed I'll
go back to bed
I'm good every Friday and Saturday
morning I lived alone that's what I live
for I try them Thursday night if I fly
into it like this week
I flew in Thursday at 11 I got the
Portland at 122 I went to my room I
rolled it John they have to sleep at
machine huh you know you get the high
Mack the iPad out yeah I [ __ ] got my
narcos going I had my feet up when I
leave the club I always rolled two
joints one for the show and one for when
I get to the hotel when I get to the
hotel on Thursday night I smoke a joint
outside there's a coffee machine in the
hallway that makes Starbucks coffee with
your credit card so I get the wide
16-ounce the holy showing up with yellow
cancer sugar and I go upstairs to my
[ __ ] bedroom with a 16-ounce black
[ __ ] stuff that [ __ ] ain't gonna give
you cancer no no and I I [ __ ] watch TV
though I you know one o'clock which it
was la time so right I don't want to 1
o'clock la time is late for Joey Diaz
oh me too that's late that I tell you
something I'm in bed by 10:00 10:30 in
case people see me other what a like he
don't come again
yeah no I have to get the key you know I
gotta get the kids to bed when they're
with me okay and Lucy
jus-just when he's done he's done he
climbs in bed
you don't even know it each us also Lucy
is a whole nother game I've got a make I
got away with her and make sure she
falls asleep and it's a whole thing with
her but yeah she's five you know she
gets scared easy she hears coyotes out
there where I live you know a man she
wants to be with daddy so my and I
always and a lot of people are like oh
you got her get her over that you got to
get over it it's like she's five she's
one day I won't be able to lay with her
because it'll be inappropriate you know
and she won't want it and she'll be too
old
right now I'm cherishing those moments
that she looked up goes daddy is it okay
no it's just a coyote he's he's just
having a good time he's trying to find
his mom see he's quiet now he thought
his mom it's amazing the time you have
to put in when you have a little girl
and what they consider like for me and
mercy it's watching YouTube so that like
I'll sell her a thousand options what
does she watch this she watched each
quest unboxing things of toys and [ __ ]
no no she wants his high school ghouls
okay see Lucy can just endlessly watch
unboxing of dolls those kids make
millions of dollars like the most
popular things on YouTube now no there's
that one kid that the American doll girl
that I forgot what her name Chloe
forget it forget booty pie this girl's
one that's making the money get those
videos at the doll just talk to each
other hmm she goes crazy you know they
just was like there's one person at the
end they somebody else is playing I even
told like oh we should do these videos
ourselves you sure they're making so
much money I would do those videos my
god could you imagine the over Diaz doll
I would play with the Joey Diaz doll I
would take that no ma'am I don't well
you got to do this I was thinking about
like why sometimes she comes up to me
I'll be selling the computers you just
you just gang Sue's me and they'll say
put this on
hold on and shoot the way she holds
sometimes you'll take my wrist and put
it over her arm which means you ain't
going nowhere she's got me I'm like a
semi [ __ ] Kimura and she holds on to
my wrist and she even does things to my
wrist so I can't get out of it way
she'll rub my wrist and [ __ ] well I'm
stuck there watching these god-awful
videos yeah I mean god-awful yes some
what'd you say to yourself you know what
what are my options this is what it's
about this is what they want yeah I
don't want Disneyland
you know we watch a lot of Peppa Pig and
stuff yes Peppa Pig you know I miss
Peppa Pig you know that the the the
YouTube platform is so amazing I love
doing vlogs and it's like I'm not making
any money doing it I didn't I'm famous
for what I want to be famous for playing
drums and poison I started that because
I have so many interests that I want to
share with people and have a good time
with it you know what I mean that's why
I started doing it but it's a whole
other headspace it's almost like they
don't want traditional media people
meddling on their platform a little bit
like other youtubers there's one guy
suburban delinquent the who is a
motorcycle guy and he does all vlogs and
motorcycle there's a couple YouTube most
of the youtubers [ __ ] completely
ignore me if I if I even reach out to
him and say hey man at school would you
never even [ __ ] respond they're just
I don't know what their [ __ ] respect
yeah I know it's like it's like but you
know they can't go on tour either like
this you know some of them can there's
some of these youtubers that are doing
if they're doing music if they already
have a talent it's one thing but if
their talent is only vlogging that's
really as far as that platform goes you
know what I mean but there are some
amazingly talented people if you dig
into YouTube what's so cool [ __ ] I'm
sorry what's so cool is that if there's
a girl in the middle of Iowa who's 16
years old again singer ass off and play
guitar
she's got an equal chance at a shot
these days of getting the world to hear
her as somebody did
years ago that had to find some way to
get somebody interested or maybe never
get a shot you know any man that's one
cool thing about the platform that I
think is so fascinating or somebody in
the middle of Germany or somewhere in
the world it's like equal you know any
man I mean how cool is that it's it that
amazes me and what I wait for those
things is that one band BLS or whatever
it is that BTS right yeah they're Korean
right something like that yeah just
outdid Taylor Taylor Swift I mean the
biggest amount of views' like ever in
history insane insane the thing I like
the most about the Internet that I don't
think people really realize is that
you're alive you have a voice now right
I don't have no excuse there's no excuse
there's no I can't get my art a gallery
you know put it online and [ __ ]
promote it I your word do you think it I
mean we were growing up you had to have
a [ __ ] sea beat oh yeah great you're
one breaker 1-9 [ __ ] out there hello
hello this is the flying Cuban yeah
anybody out there you know now as you
pick up chicks on the CB you know if I
was a 13 year old kid right now there's
no reason to even go to USC the media
school no more
I mean look at you know everybody has
access to a camera like this or the
phone or something like that you can
tell a story now it doesn't mean you're
gonna tell a story we've all had pet
people and pens or pencils doesn't mean
you're gonna write a great book but you
have the ability of your ability you
know I love that's all of the most yeah
whether it's going to be good or bad
that's up to you and you don't have to
worry about that that's not important
the most important thing is that you get
whatever you have on your mind or in
your heart out and you gonna honestly
say I tried to get it out 13 people
watched it but this Dirt
people know the [ __ ] I have right
this looks nice I mean why I have a
small channel but the people that are
there are very focus in there's a lot of
people that you know people are throwing
me some cool gear and stuff like that
because they're like at least I know the
people that are watching and they're
gonna look at this gear so I'm there's a
local motorcycle shop I'm gonna do some
reviews for them on some of the new
bikes and it's building it's taken time
you know it's like the reason why I go
jiu-jitsu I go to jiu-jitsu I don't go
there to be muchacha what to be John
Jacques you know I go to jiu-jitsu bro
to be a fat guy in the back that's just
a fat blue belt in the back it's nice to
have that feeling once in a while you
can't be Rikki Rockett
every [ __ ] day no I can't
could you imagine if anybody who talked
to you all they talked he was about
[ __ ] drama well I don't know we love
dramas my so you love percussion but can
you imagine every [ __ ] body who came
up to you was you question when you were
writing every rose has its thorn how was
your input can I just be Ricky can I be
[ __ ] a brown bear dude this is this
is why I do this for this is no I think
I love you to death now I do other
things sometimes I'll do a drum thing or
I'll do it what you saw Wow life but I
but that's that's my work okay and I
don't hate it I love my work but I don't
necessarily want to talk about it I'm
sorry here's other stuff I want to talk
about and if it falls short and people
aren't into it then there's nothing but
you know I'm trying my son is at the age
now he's starting to know who I am and
my impact for better or for worse on the
world like he'll listen to a band and
he'll goes are they more famous or than
you I don't know Jude you know it's like
that's a hard one day answer but he's
starting to get it he's starting to get
it and that's kind of weird a little bit
it's like we were talking at the very
beginning I don't know if we were on the
air when we were talking about it we're
talking about how Hollywood was just
littered with the ghosts of past actors
and their kids
they're siblings and everybody you know
in a man it's so weird you know don't
you know who my dad was and I don't want
Jude or Lucy to ever live in my shadow
for better or worse for better or worse
I want them to stand on their own you
know in a man I want them to be their
own person and be loved for their like
the guy in The Wallflowers say never he
never talks about his dad being Bob
Dylan I mean he's [ __ ] wallflowers
and the [ __ ] wallflowers with or
without Dylan yeah it's kid you know in
a minute I mean that's kind of cool you
know
that's important there really isn't and
I want that for Jude sure will it help
him that I have some of these
connections and stuff it may or it may
not say you know sometimes people
prejudge it right off the bat you know
sometimes they don't want you know what
is so weird I was thinking about this I
was thinking about this earlier today
when I was washing my truck sometimes I
just like to wash my truck because I
don't trust anybody else to do it right
I was thinking that you know in the 70s
for example when a musician had
something to say a lot of people would
look at that musician and go wow I like
their music I like the subjects they
talk about and those things ring true
I'm gonna take what they have to say
with a little bit of weight you know
what I mean so if they're protesting
something I really want to know what
they're thinking about I'm kind of with
them on that you know maybe they have a
good point nowadays it's like you're the
show monkey so don't [ __ ] opinionate
on anything just do your job and shut up
that's how it's getting a little bit I
think that's weird
and I think that's sad you know any man
it's like if somebody doesn't agree with
DeNiro saying something about Trump
let's say what she's been outspoken
about that then all of a sudden De
Niro's a shitty actor now these days are
gone as [ __ ] Baba he can't say anything
bad about the knurl come on really
you may not like what he's saying about
Trump but I just feel like it's the
opinions of people have changed they
don't want to hear anymore they
musicians are back to like way back into
the 40s now where we don't want your
opinion just give us a show and shut up
you know a man there was so much more
influential in the 60s and 70s but we're
not there anymore what about you know
we've been pushed back nope
it's hard to get people to want to hear
anything that I have to say unless it
has to do with music you know I mean
have you noticed that or am I alone in
this are you - hi - no you know it's
like what a fighter is a fighter and he
gets into movies people watch him
because he's a fighter and a movie a
fireman
right see but a lot of fighters will get
out of fighting
thinking they're gonna have a movie
career afterward right it's very tough
it'd still be five actors it's hard for
actors to make the switch to music
Johnny Depp one of the most famous
actors in the whole world I mean he's
one of the few people that have been
able to cross over a little bit but it's
not like he has a number one selling
record you know what I mean but he's
playing without with Joe Perry and I was
kupo you know he's doing the Hollywood
vampires that at least he's able to live
out that part of his dream but it's very
very hard for actors to just between you
and I okay we taste right now I got a
Hollywood dream - I would love to play
[ __ ] music I would love to play the
bass or whatever let's pretend tomorrow
I went and [ __ ] got a guitar and I
went three [ __ ] chords or whatever
and all of a sudden I got into a movie
and I got a really popular you know
sometimes it's just it's very it's like
when Don Johnson made an album it's very
tough to take an actor to just like yeah
that was driving and I heard Jennifer
Lopez music and I remember when that
album came out thinking to myself who
told [ __ ] and Jennifer she could sing
right and she's
set for seven I'm putting it down it's
very tough to win over guys like me that
are old katey sagal but that girl has an
incredible voice you know a man yo you
know from dogs anarchy yeah real she
said she did my half of the soundtrack
of Sons of Anarchy she's an incredible
singer a lot of people don't know why
she goes on tour and I didn't know what
the [ __ ] she was talking about she's
phenomenal
yeah she's she [ __ ] tears it up dude
yeah you wouldn't know it you know but
yeah it's hard to make the crossover I
mean I remember reading an article not
that long ago that was talking about
bands in the Greater Los Angeles area
30,000 organized in some disorganized
bands okay
30,000 I don't think there's 30,000
clubs in the United States that you
could go play at I mean all these
musicians going you know any man I mean
it's it's competitive everybody wants to
be a rock star you know it's it's it's a
[ __ ] just to just to make a living
doing it is hard just to figure out how
to make a living you must know this with
comedy [ __ ] that's a lonely job man I
don't know how you do it
that takes some intestinal fortitude you
get all my respect I'll tell you walking
out on that stage and trying to like get
people to laugh and [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
[ __ ] talk that's tough
that is tough I I don't think I can't
even imagine and it's so weird how what
I'm doing on stage now is the results of
the work I put it in the 90s and with
him being close to 2020 and I'm seeing
the results from with the work I put in
the manganese now so it's such a it's
it's the journey brother yeah
the journey is it's a beautiful [ __ ]
journey and you need to pick a good one
or you could pick a bad one you have a
choice so you can make a [ __ ] great
choice you know sometimes I do these
acoustic gigs with with Brannon Gibbs a
singer for devil city angels we're just
doing acoustic ATAR just be him and on
you know he plays guitar I'll play a
cone or something like that and we'll
tell some stories in between and I'm
always laughing and telling jokes I like
to tell jokes but I can hide behind the
instrument at the end of the day at the
end of the day if nobody's laughing it's
like okay the next song you know any
minute
and it's the end of it with you if it
ain't working man I mean what do you do
you know I mean you can't get mad at
people you know well I mean that that
that's like counterproductive no two
different phases of your journey the
first two years you blame the audience
you know there's always a blame until
you become a comedian accept it and just
be better the next day
it's a horrible feeling to bounce it's a
horrible horrible horrible feelings to
bomb did you ever have have you ever
been on a stage and bombed with a band
oh yeah
what's bombing with a band like it sucks
I remember I was just telling this story
not long ago Brett and I were in another
band that we played a 4-wheel Drive
convention in Williamsburg Pennsylvania
and it was the only oh god 81 or
something like that
and the only time they clapped is when
we said we were taking a break you know
and now I'm a four-wheel guy right but
it's just ya know it sucks man when you
bomb that hard or when you people just
don't react at all and I think that's
what made us work so hard cuz we had to
work so hard back there to get a
reaction you know and that's in
Pennsylvania yeah you gotta work real
[ __ ] hard yeah that's that's why you
know I think we belong in a category of
our own we always said that we were the
the blue-collar glam band you know any
man here we were you know we definitely
weren't a dandy you know as they would
say in
and you know my dad was a taxi driver
you know how glamorous can i really be
but we fooled everybody you know I like
that we our work ethic is really what
what drove it and I think still does we
still have a great work ethic when this
band gets together we work our ass off
how long do you rehearse before the tour
starts yeah but usually about two weeks
you know something like that
and and several those days are just
figuring out your instruments yeah how
did you know trying to get everything to
work together just sussing out your
sound getting your text to be on board
you know a lot of its production and and
I don't go on stage nervous because I
can't play the songs because I've been
playing these songs a long time so I'm
not worried about that I'm worried about
something not working right you go out
on stage and something [ __ ] fails you
know I'm always worried about the the
thing that I can't control and that's
the thing that makes me not satisfy I
have o CDs because I can't control every
aspect though this would happen a lot
every you know it's always gonna happen
the first show at least you know and
then you start to get used to it
everything's going you're cruising along
and then you drop your guard and that's
when it happens again you're not a man
as soon as you drop your guard something
wrong happens how many shows are you
doing this last tour not that many well
he did like 36 38 something like that
yeah so it was only like eight seven
weeks or something we were doing five
nights a week but on a bus oh yeah I
love my boss are you kidding me it's
your old bike on my own bus yeah I don't
own it we lease our buses but when we
hit our 20-year anniversary we went now
we got a in order to keep doing this we
need a little space if we can make it
happen Motley Crue was doing at
Aerosmith so we did it and it is best I
could stay out there honest to god if it
wasn't for my kids I could almost just
actually stay on the road I got a
trailer with my motorcycle on that some
of my [ __ ] I don't need a hotel most of
the time sometimes I get up in the
morning go in and do the buffet come
back out to my bus no my clothes are
there all my stuff so I love I live in
the bus
yes all that bathroom shower bed it's
fantastic so when you guys travel each
have your own bus yeah yep that's how we
do it because people will be like man
aren't you you guys are like brothers
like what happened it's like I love my
sister I don't want to live with her
love her to death I don't want to live
with her
I love Brett Bobby and CeCe don't want
to live with them I see them on stage I
see them in the morning at catering you
know any man will play a little football
in the afternoon go out and do a sound
check do the show that's good we don't
have to be in each other's faces 24/7
that's not good trust me
and everything's change there's no more
drinking I mean there's no more you know
I really mean I can drink I don't so
much because of what I went through it
actually hurt burns you know so I don't
drink anymore very rarely I don't think
you know Brett's diabetic so he can't
drink that Bobby and CC were both sober
so so they don't drink completely
totally Suzy had no fart Cece is not and
has not thank God thank God he would
have died I mean the fact of the matter
is when you get to that level one or two
things is gonna happen you're either
gonna die or you're gonna stop either
way you're gonna stop you know what man
cuz you can't just keep doing it I'm
always here been sober for about nine
years at least yeah 11 I saw him his kid
changed everything for him and you hear
about this you know oh my kid change it
they really did it changed it he gave up
all that [ __ ] to make sure he was there
for valent he's a good dad he's a you
know Bobby's same thing he's there for
his kids
you know you have to be yeah you have to
be and and Brett's never been able to
party to that same I mean I you know he
parties but not he can't drink like a
fish
I mean we did all that [ __ ] in the early
days he did it in spite of being a
diabetic and there was times where I was
like [ __ ] he's gonna die you know what I
mean and I think he went yeah I can't do
this or I'm gonna die you know and so
what's more important going on stage and
playing or doing that until you can't do
it anymore and we made the choice we
want to keep playing and it's not easy
that's you know I mean you're insulated
as a rock guy I mean I could do any drug
I wanted and I'm never gonna get caught
for it probably I mean I'm in that tour
bus oh I'm bad you know it whatever I
got security I'm insulated I can [ __ ]
do drugs till the cows come home I can
just obliterate myself the only people
are gonna care that I'm alive or the
promoters and managers and people that
want me to get on that stage every night
you know what I mean but the minute that
tour is over they don't get I'm back to
me caring about myself you know inside
and that's where people go down that
rabbit hole when all of a sudden there's
nobody there picking you up and going no
no no no you got to get up you can't you
know you know and you just that's when
it really can go bad for people so you
know thankfully for me I just never I
think I think I experimented with so
much stuff when I was younger that I
just didn't care about it when I got to
this place when I got to the point where
we were touring I did party I ain't
gonna lie about it but I never got
addicted to anything but cigarettes you
know that was the only thing I ever got
friend girls I got very addicted to girl
but I didn't get addicted to drugs I
just didn't care about coke like
everybody else did that would have taken
me the [ __ ] down cuz when I when I'm
into something I'm [ __ ] into it I mean
I'd have stayed scales and all that [ __ ]
I mean when I was when I smoked a lot of
pot I had every [ __ ] pot thing that
you could imagine I was like stamping
making leather [ __ ] clips and [ __ ] I
mean I was into it
if when I get into something I get
massively into it I have a very
addictive personality thank God I'm not
addicted to any drugs because if I was
I'd be dead I'd be [ __ ]
dad thank God all you guys are still
together and you can still do your thing
and nothing bad happened to end the band
lot of bands end with a you know bad
ending Wednesday I mean it's tough stuff
yeah it is talking tough man but I mean
it's tough to hold a band I got a we've
been together 32 years almost 33 years
it's it's hard to hold it together you
know as mad as I get at these guys and I
get [ __ ] mad at these guys you know
they I can't get them to do what I want
them to do you know but I still respect
them and that's the bottom line
at the end of the day I think we have
respect for each other even if we're
[ __ ] mad at each other I could be mad
at Brett for two [ __ ] years I'm still
gonna respect them you know cuz if it
wasn't for him I wouldn't be where I'm
at if it wasn't for me he wouldn't be
where he was I mean you know the we were
you know I come from a place okay where
a band is a gang with instruments okay
and there's loyalty there today bands
are two interchangeable that I think the
members are two interchangeable people
look the same and one guy jumps from one
band to the other there's not the
commitment you knew and I'm saying I
like when a band looks like a [ __ ]
gang and that's that's what I think we
came from and I you know Motley Crue was
like that you know I mean van Halen you
know Marilyn Manson I mean if you shave
your [ __ ] eyebrow you do something
over the top so that it it's cohesive
you know because I believe that
everything comes from your attitude your
attitude makes you play you set a
soundtrack to your attitude you talk and
do interviews from your attitude you
look the way you look because of your
attitude that's the core thing you know
what I mean is is that attitude thing
and I think it's sorely missing from
music these days because people are
looking and going I don't know what kind
of music I want to do I just want to
play something I'm good with whatever it
is and
maybe I should come up with some kind of
an image and they get it all [ __ ] up
you know a man and it's like no guys
start at the core at the core what were
you at really are you an angry guy are
you a happy person or you you know you
know what is it that really rings true
and then start to build your your your
whole story out of that you know in a
man I want my music if I'm angry I want
my music to be angry I want to look I
want my clothes to look like this I want
to talk like this so this is Who I am I
can look in the mirror every day and do
it I don't have to remember anything
because I'm telling the truth every day
you know and I mean to me that's what a
real rock band does they tell the truth
every day you know what I mean and I
look at so many musicians today and it's
like wow it's just so calculated yeah
I can't buy into little [ __ ] if I'm
buying into it I'm buying into some
social media guy that's sitting
somewhere else coming up with this [ __ ]
you know any man you know I come from
the basements of [ __ ] the east coast
where we went hacked it out you know and
I mean that's that's that's what it's
really about that's why those all those
bands are so great you know I mean I'm
looking at Black Sabbath right there you
know these guys [ __ ] and yeah they
didn't come from them from the swanky
part of [ __ ] England I mean they were
grinding it out man with the rest of
everybody but music was the most
important thing to them you know and
they would sacrifice for it but there's
a certain personal sacrifice I've always
said that real true art and I know I'm
just blabbing here but real true art has
got to come from a personal place and I
think it does with you and I can see
that and your stand well it took years
that's the other side of that then it
took years it took years you guys out
with poison also it takes a little years
to get those layers off yes it's not a
lot of people who wanna tell the truth
listen there's not a lot of peanut who
want you to know who they are now 50% of
people really want you to know they are
you know what's going on now with music
is
and I think it's society we all have
costumes oh yeah he's got a [ __ ]
costume now I've never seen more of a
society with a costume there's more
costumes yeah when I was growing up you
had an afro you had long hair but you
had sure there that's it
you had an afro you had sure their dick
in there oh you had long hair hasn't
even come along yeah I love that now I
got guys it's 90 degrees you're wearing
a ski cap so I gotta be impressed with
your music you know it's like they sell
so many different things that once I see
that I get turned off like I thought
well I think a lot of people wear things
and have stand behind an attitude but
that they don't even know what it means
in the first place you know what I'm
saying nothing burns me up more than
some pop total total popstar wearing
like a metallic assured I was like you
ain't [ __ ] in the Metallica what do
you do no no you know and then it's like
you know come on it's just it's become a
fashion thing it's be kind of some way
of that's well isn't that cute you know
in a man it's like last wee years ago
they have like two lineups that played
down and I don't know what they wanted
for the tickets my friend Josh most went
and he said the same thing there was a
lot of people on there that paid the 500
house and didn't even know why they were
down it didn't know who the who was
didn't know who the stones when they
just bought the t-shirt 48 dollars at
the door and when lettuce eat be
somebody well that's when I try to
remember there's a lot you know with a
lot of these younger people they don't
know who poison is some dudes some don't
only if they decide that they want to
learn about it like a lot of people
don't knew Bruce Lee is okay we'll go
back to that beginning okay they didn't
know the Wolfman Jack was oh [ __ ] two
weeks ago I said so massive Wolfman Jack
out for the Wolfman that's entirely
weird when you it's really weird when
you talk yeah mad at you know yeah
I'm on that I don't know yeah yeah you
could call them it's just weird that
little man Jack a couple weeks ago but I
was playing Jersey and my buddy's a
longshoreman and he goes I'm getting off
I'll swing by to see you and he came by
and we had dinner at Old Town then he
went home belize's as he was walking to
his car he saw a young kid from work I
think it was redoing and he goes I came
to meet my buddy for tell me what are
you doing he goes I'm here to see Joey
Diaz because that's what I was having
dinner with so how the kid bothers him
so he said a couple weeks ago dice was
playing for Lior and one part of Jersey
and he went up to know you know dice is
in Forli playing the kids like who's
that
and he goes some wait a second you know
this old guy is Joey do you know I'm
saying like they'd you know know I was
talking to a friend of mine that does
she show runner he's doing their ice ice
ice tea show you know the true crime
shown right and people today don't know
that he was an influential serious
[ __ ] rapper they know him from what
CSI or what it would show was on order
Law & Order that's what they know him
that's the guy from long I believe he's
doing that not the rapper I mean I see
him as the rapper I mean does if he's
doing New Year's Eve with Ozzy his band
is doing New Year's Eve ice-t is yeah
what's name of that band what sniffing
he brought that band back yeah cool
looking up uh eyes faster they're doing
[ __ ] new using what the [ __ ] was that
man uh that really good album yeah you
[ __ ] good out yeah it was like heavy
metal yeah I [ __ ] was he was
phenomenal
yeah body count bloody cow yeah yeah
I've it wasn't Marty's hit the floor was
that no that song I should know this
anybody watching you can [ __ ]
lambaste please ask for not known if I
give this guy you know you have so much
on your mind you can't remember
everything you can't remember everything
but yeah [ __ ] body count is it with
ice-t
yes but the Ozzfest debut of
account featuring iced tea yeah and you
[ __ ] believe that
that's [ __ ] easy that goodbye Marilyn
Manson Rob Zombie Jonathan Davis and
body count at the flowing profits will
be twelve hours holy [ __ ] you know by
the time I think it starts like what
time using here yeah it's crazy yeah
well and I was telling a story that
somebody called me and said hey we have
a function we're really interesting you
and playing it down New Year's and I
told my wife and huh what do you have to
lose and they go it's 10:30 though we
want you to go on between 10:30 and
11:00 I was like you know because I
thought about them like I was I don't
like going up that late on these if I do
anything it's at the ice house early and
two days later they announced this and
I'm like thank God you know you know
what one thing I want to talk about too
that I forgot to mention when we were
talking about earlier like you know some
things just had that feeling to it and
all that kind of stuff
we played Bethel New York where
Woodstock was and I did a vlog about it
okay because I was so moved by the whole
thing I was not a Woodstock I was too
young
my sister wanted to go my sister is nine
years is nine years older than me and so
I took a tour of Woodstock like where
the whole thing happened and I called
the vlog sacred ground because it
they've made it like an ant and like a
monument literally now I have you ever
been there
no Bethel New York is really a nice
place by the way I have a beautiful you
love it's close to that I have a friend
who lives close to that they told me
about that they had they restored
something oh it's beautiful and they
have a museum there and they have all
kinds of art and I mean it's just
totally worth it going for the day and
hanging out there's a concert up there
go to it I mean it was great so I did a
vlog about it called sacred ground and I
tried to insert like the crowds from
Woodstock in the areas that I was
standing in like where would have been
and where the stage was there's a little
controversy exactly where the stage was
but you can tell by some of the tree
lines and stuff like that they've got it
pretty much figured out you know in a
man but how cool man just you know you
get a feeling that mean there though
there were plenty there's plenty of
festivals but that one was truly [ __ ]
special I bought a drum kit I love
Rogers drums and I bought a drum kit
from a guy who was the drummer in a band
called eternity children and in 1969
they broke out right or maybe in the 70s
but in 69 they had their first hit
that's when the drum kit was from he
didn't play quit yet when the band broke
up he just put the drums in a closet
didn't touch him I bought him from him
what two three years ago
[ __ ] awesome right they were supposed
to play Woodstock they turned it down
wasn't enough money and they didn't like
the time of day so they said [ __ ] it
we're gonna go to Atlanta and play at
club we'll make more money so they
didn't do Woodstock he told me this
whole story and can you imagine what it
completely changed everything but it was
just it's just where there's so many
stories like that they were trying to
you know there was like that band
Sweetwater you know but I was like man
somebody needs to do a [ __ ]
documentary want your band because they
actually had two songs were almost hits
they were like in the top 30 or it's top
20 or something like that a lot of
Eternity children welcome up it's kind
of crazy I didn't know anything about it
had never heard of him until but he
signed a [ __ ] head for me I have that
drum kit it's kind of cool Rikki Rockett
always a [ __ ] pleasure always a
pleasure always you always come up with
something [ __ ] interesting oh I can
talk and talk man I'll put people to
sleep I had a girlfriend that almost
[ __ ] put to sleep drive in one time I
thought you just abandon knowledge
that's why I love you to death well we
got a train we didn't talk about jujitsu
Hurley you know we talked about other
martial arts and stuff like that and
that next
I mean we'll talk about yeah Jitsu a
little more but you fight you said you
were gonna come and you did you're a man
of your word
you came you [ __ ] train had a good
time he don't work me that day that was
a real private hey man
sometimes sometimes he gets a [ __ ]
that that was nothing that some days he
gets a hair up his ass that but you
always [ __ ] respect first from that
man and not Renato magno was one of the
I respect that man as much as anybody
could respect anybody I'm telling you
he's a prize every day almost every day
every day yeah different people
different time still with Danny on Asano
I saw those privates with Danny I mean
he's teaching Danny he's teaching Yoda
that's pretty badass I don't know if
Danny would like me calling them Yoda
but to me that's the biggest compliment
you can pay somebody you know I mean
when I walked in that's the second time
I've seen him when I [ __ ] my pants
I had word that I can just to keep it
together because I know exactly what and
who he was I know we can go on game of
death and want to turn him on he turned
Bruce Lee on all that [ __ ] all those
weapons and stuff that's [ __ ] he was
a gym teacher you know that like at a
high school or something
Danny was or a college or something I
hope I'm getting this right he's a
pretty amazing deal you really is you
know what they did one time they'll just
wrap it up with a and the cast was
telling me cast Magda was telling me
that at one point Bruce got interested
in how hard football players were able
to hit another guy and take him down
okay
he wasn't just interested in the
wrestling aspect he thought wolf I can
[ __ ] hit somebody that hard imagine
what I can do if I try to hit him
wrestle him and then beat him on the
ground this is what Bruce was thinking
about so Danny got one of those what do
they call him that did you [ __ ] his
legs yeah and Broughton's in Bruce's
backyard they practiced on these [ __ ]
things this is how forward-thinking he
was
about all this kind of stuff and Danny's
got all this rolling around in his head
you know any man and it's just uh
there's so much that's why don't do
drugs anymore because there's so many
neat things to do it learn about awesome
it would just [ __ ] would get in the way
but you're a [ __ ] animal brother
always a pleasure
give me a line please no any time you're
free you want to come down and I'll try
to see you after the 19th I'm gonna come
down there okay let's see what's they
come back from New York I'm gonna have a
lot more time so like I said I'm barely
getting twice a week at my place
I love embarrassed about it I like
trying to get in 3 or 4 times a week I
do too yeah I've been like doing two and
threes a good week for me and it sucks
because I lose timing and all kinds of
[ __ ] I do the Muay Thai conditioning
twice a week and I also do power
strength lifting with a lady a coach
twice a week just awesome you know I'm
55 see the road will [ __ ] you up if
you're not bad for the road oh yeah you
know your hips your knees your back hell
flying the driving the sitting it's
rough it's [ __ ] rough the beat
jumping away so uh I've been really
taking it seriously but man anytime you
want to come on in and just chitchat
this is your second [ __ ] home I love
you to death
a nod said he was gonna come down I gave
him the address and but he didn't show
I'll call him tomorrow I'm gonna call
him tomorrow anyway I like to get him
I'm scared to look at this score 30 30
and the fourth with 410 remains it's
right oh come on
Bixby [ __ ] boy wait a minute
touchdown Steelers watch touchdown what
will my updating now come on update
update update that's a family right
there oh yeah that's the [ __ ] fan
right there come on what's up here I
want to thank my man Ricky Rocket thank
you for having me I want to thank the
Chris the flying Jew the original
[ __ ]
fella from Manila Lisa at will be with
me this weekend in La Jolla opening up
the
[ __ ] show I'm so excited I'm
excited that you're coming [ __ ]
and that's it I'll see you guys
Thursday more than tip top module love
you stay black have a great [ __ ] day
tell them all to suck your dick alright
I want to thank my man Ricky Rocket I
want to thank the [ __ ] but most
importantly I want to thank you
[ __ ] on a Monday morning for a
support in the church and for listening
and for hanging out with us listen as
usual we got sponsors all right
the holidays are here and it's the
busiest time of year what do you have to
do on the holidays in here to-do list
you got a lot of errands to run right or
wrong as you know the holidays are busy
especially at the post office that's why
you got to use stamps calm it saves you
so much time during this hectic holiday
season stamps out Tom brings the US
service brings all the services of the
US Post Office right to your desk right
there to your home you print postage any
day any time stamps calm is always open
stamps calm the only save your time it
saves your money because stamps not
calmed helps you print out the right
amount of postage every time you've
never overpaid again and with stamps
calm you get discounts on postage you
can't even get at the post office with
all that time and money you'll save
stamps.com is the best gift you give
yourself this holiday season like I said
whether your business is big or small my
wife uses stamps calm to send our church
mugs rash guards you know all that stuff
we used to Stan stop calm and it makes
my wife job a lot easier every morning
when I leave I see a couple packages on
post on the mailbox but by the time I
come back they're gone
the mailman takes them it's that easy so
right now you can enjoy stamps.com
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial for weeks
free plus postage and a digital scale
without long term commitments this is
beautiful right now during the holiday
season and you're gonna you're gonna try
it you're gonna go Jesus I've sent all
these gifts out right here from my house
is amazing
so go to Stan's calm right now click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage
typing Joey that stamps calm and - Joey
another great sponsor on it they've been
there since day one from the shroom text
more to the shroom tech immune to the
Mexican chocolate protein you can't go
wrong do me a favor go to adam.com right
now impress in church and get the
product delivered to your house like I
told you in the beginning start with the
Alpha brain see how it gets and make
sure the nootropics is the way to go
number two I'm gonna be at the temblor
brewing house up in Bakersfield December
12th and a Wednesday night and then the
Thursday after Christmas I think it's
the 27th I'm up there at the Oxnard
improv levity live in Oxnard so if
you're looking for tickets that's the
way to go no New Year's yet no nothing
just those through those two dates I'm a
lawyer this weekend but it sold out if
you didn't get tickets it's a small
intimate place so go [ __ ] yourself I
don't know what to tell you besides that
I love your [ __ ] with all my
heart I had a great time up in Portland
helium you're [ __ ] great Club and the
Portland audiences look great I want to
thank you for coming out and I want to
thank you guys for listening to the show
that's the most important thing and for
supporting us and giving us love on the
internet I love you guys with all my
heart I'll see you guys Thursday morning
ready to rock tip-top [ __ ] Magoo
kick this [ __ ] melee